President Biden has announced new
immigration policies ahead of his visit
to El Paso this weekend the city has
been struggling to cope with an influx
of migrants seeking asylum in the U.S
the new policies are aimed at reducing
the number of illegal Crossings at the
U.S Mexico border each month up to 30
000 people from four countries Venezuela
Haiti Nicaragua and Cuba will be
accepted if they can prove they have a
financial sponsor in the United States
but those who enter the U.S illegally
may be expelled to Mexico under title 42
a rising number of migrants from Cuba
and Haiti is also arriving by boat in
Florida where another humanitarian
crisis is unfolding Manuel bojorquez has
that part of the story
U.S Coast Guard video shows agents
encountering people on rafts or crowded
boats taking on water
the arrival of more than 300 migrants at
Dry Tortugas a national park in the
Florida Keys this week led to the Park's
temporary closure even cruise ships have
stopped to rescue people at Sea Asylum
Seekers hoping for this
a reunion with family members already in
the U.S like Edie's Fundora from Cuba
who arrived in the keys after a week at
Sea with her two boys
content you're happy they're part of a
recent rise in crossings by sea since
October 1st of 2022 the Customs and
Border Protection Miami sector reports a
400 percent increase in migrant
encounters
many Cubans say they are fleeing
political persecution at the hands of
the communist government but also an
economy that has gone from bad to worse
Haitians are fleeing their Homeland too
as the country descends further into
chaos gang violence and hunger they do
not risk their lives unless what they
leave behind is worse than death Leone
is with Saint law a community resource
center for Haitians in Miami we spoke
with her just as another boat full of
Haitians arrived in Key Largo this week
when your country does not provide you
with the safety the security and staying
in there is worse than death that as
they say they rather go deal with the
dangers of the sea yet for many the
journey ends in deportation and a return
to the very country and conditions from
which they fled for CBS mornings I'm
Manuel bojorquez in the Florida Keys